courtesy of uncle sam american supplied
armor now riding under taliban colours
the spoils of victory being paraded by
the new masters of kandahar
an extraordinary site in the city where
their movement began and where they
could now bask in triumph
their ragtag desert army now mechanized
even with the odd helicopter
propaganda gold for jihadists the world
over
but they're not just playing with new
toys in kabul there are reports the
taliban is securing its grip carrying
out atrocities we spoke to one afghan in
hiding because he'd worked as a
translator
anonymously he relayed reports of
taliban squads moving through the city
hunting down anyone who worked with
their enemies they just killed 10 people
in one street
they killed people anonymously and they
just killed them during the night
ten people were killed in the night
yeah ten people were killing the night
they were all
working in afghan government
in bagram air base jail former inmates
revisit the site of their incarceration
more propaganda showing the taliban
consolidating its control its leaders
have made promises to the west on human
rights women executions that aren't
being kept analysts say it can't be
trusted it's not entirely clear that the
taliban knows exactly how they're going
to govern they seem to be a little bit
surprised that they took the country as
quickly as they did
but we also have to remember
the taliban have been sanctioned for
their support for terrorist groups in
the past and while not necessarily the
rank and file many of the senior members
of the taliban are
the heads of mafia and organized crime
organizations it's a criminally captured
state
outside banks more queues of afghans
desperate to get their money out
it's been two days that we are here
there are a lot of problems i request
the authorities of the islamic emirate
to reopen all the bank branches inside
kabul
the taliban will need assistance to run
the country but if abuses go on can
britain america and others really have
the stomach to help them
dominic waghorn sky news